Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. Although I'm filming this five days ago, a past so distant,
I'm sure we're already looking back on it with fondness.
Anyway
today's video is like the Saturn 5 rocket it comes to you in three parts of which the first part is by far the longest
Part one: other John Greens. Not to brag but over the last 40 years
I've become something of an expert in the field of people named John Green
So today I thought I would introduce you to six of my favorite John Greens who aren't me
First John Green the Bigfoot expert. Often called one of the Four Horsemen of Sasquatchery, John Green was a small-town newspaper
publisher until the age of 45 when he left his career behind to become a full-time Bigfoot researcher.
John Green went on to write several books arguing that large,
Human-like Apes roam the woods of North America including Year of the Sasquatch which I actually own it's not bad
fun fact John Green once wrote into Mental Floss magazine after I
Implied in an article that Bigfoot didn't exist saying that I had besmirched the good name of John Greens everywhere
secondly
We have professor John Green this John Green has a great beard and just recently became the interim president of the University
Of Akron John Green is a professor of political science who researches the intersection between religion and politics and American life
So, you know, that'll keep you busy then
There's John Green the artist who's maybe my favorite John Green because he is the co-creator of the amazing graphic novel series teen boat
Which is about a young man who has all of the normal problems of being a teenager
but also occasionally turns into a yacht John Green has said it's the only comic that features the angst of being a teen and
The thrill of being a boat John Green also does lots of art for comics and video games
You've probably seen his work fourth. We have another bookish John Green sticker and coloring book author. John Green who has been haunting me since
1998 when the bookstore at my college began to sell his sticker books
I don't know much about this John Green except that I think he's into horses
His books include horses tattoo favorite horses stickers little horses stained-glass
Coloring book and both horses of the world and wonderful world of horses, which seems a little redundant to me
But I'm not here to criticize that guy has published more books about horses than I have published books
Fifth John Green the designer this British. John Green makes excellent furniture for instance
He created the cool embrace coffee table, which works two ways
and then lastly we have John Green the
Cinematographer who is technically a John Green
Even if he does go by Jack John Green has often been the director of photography for movies directed by Clint Eastwood
In fact, he was nominated for an Oscar for Unforgiven, but he's also been the cinematographer for a huge range of movies
He's worked on good movies
Like twister and speed 2 he's worked on great movies like the net and he's worked on all-time
Classics like Rookie of the Year. That's not a joke. By the way Rookie of the Year is a phenomenal movie
Don't at me did that sound hip and young slight side note that John Green has not yet won an Oscar
But John Greens as a whole have. In fact, John Green the composer won four Academy Awards and also one Grammy
meanwhile
John Green
The TV producer has won three Emmys meaning that we are only
One Tony Award away from a John Green EGOT based on my singing and acting talents
I don't think I'm going to be the one to win it
But maybe that sticker book guy is in the new cats
Part to the tour Hank in September and October you are going on the road in support of your brilliant first novel An Absolutely Remarkable
Thing which comes out, September 25th and is available for pre-order now and I will be joining you in, New York, Boston, North Canton
Ohio Kansas City Chicago and Indianapolis. I am so excited for the tour
It is gonna be a blast ticket info in the doobly-doo below and lastly part three, you are likely familiar with the phrase
Don't forget to be awesome, but do you remember that
Our catchphrase was in fact invented not by us. But by my friend Katie else in 2007
Katie is an acclaimed singer of Irish music and her new album
Songs from across the lake and sea has just come out. It is beautiful and haunting and just wonderful
There's a link to her music in the doobly-doo below Hank. I will see you on Friday